[Music]
okay so I've tried to upload a few
Deadpool videos the past couple of days
and each time I try it either gets
blocked before it gets posted or it gets
posted for like three hours and then
gets taken down
so thanks Fox on a bunch of a-holes so
this is me attempting to yet again
re-upload my videos so you all can see
them but Fox be like kidding though not
on my watch
so in order to get the video and
information out to you for your viewing
pleasure here's a bunch of random clips
and photos we're gonna try the Deadpool
to post-credit scene explained again
there are two scenes to look out for and
of course if you haven't seen the movie
spoiler alert
also if you are new to my channel we are
currently doing a giveaway for a free
speaker system all you have to do is
subscribe and the rest of the steps are
in the description below so the first
scene is pretty simple we learn in the
movie that cable has a time-travel
device but at the end we learned that he
has used it all the amounts that he can
so in the post credits scene they showed
negasonic teenage warhead and ukyo
fixing that device for Deadpool so that
he can use it again so what does this
mean well it's pretty simple
Deadpool asked them to fix the device so
he could go back in time himself and
tinker with things what does he want to
change well you find out in the next
post-credit scene so that was the first
scene but it quickly cuts to the second
scene which is really like four scenes
in one the first of which is deadpool
going back to the scene where vanessa
was shot and killed and he saves her by
throwing the cream cheese knife in the
villains face immediately killing him
and saving Vanessa's life he then says
I'll be right back and leaves yelling
we're definitely naming our kids Cher so
what does this mean does this mean that
Vanessa is actually brought back to life
and she'll be in the next Deadpool movie
yes yes it does so it looks like
Deadpool and Vanessa are finally gonna
get their opportunity to have a family
and I really like that they did this
because I was super pissed in the
beginning of the movie when they killed
her the next scene Deadpool goes back
to where Peter parachutes to the ground
and tells him to go home Peter then
replies this has been pretty scary and
agrees to go home but not before asking
Deadpool to give Domino his email
address but the most interesting thing
about the scene is he only goes back and
saves Peter he doesn't go back and save
anyone else an x-force that died why is
this could it be that he really is Peter
wisdom from the comics and that's why he
saved his life because he needs to show
up in Deadpool 3 I guess we're gonna
have to wait until that movie comes out
to find out the next scene is awesome
and it's hilarious they go back to the
x-men origin Wolverine original film
that they did and Deadpool kills the
version of Deadpool in that movie
it shows Wolverine bringing out his
claws and just before the other Deadpool
is about to bring out his swords
Deadpool shows up and shoots him in the
head
Deadpool then walks into the scene and
says hey it's me don't scratch just
cleaning up the timeline he then
proceeds to shoot the other Deadpool
eight more times this is awesome because
everybody really just did not like that
original x-men origin movie and
everybody particularly hated the way
they portrayed Deadpool in that movie
this is just Ryan Reynolds making fun of
himself which I love and which brings us
into the last post credits scene the
scene shows Ryan Reynolds holding a
scrip in his hand and he looks at it all
in love with it and says welcome to the
big leagues kid it then shows the script
says Green Lantern on it Deadpool then
shoots Ryan Reynolds in the head and
gets blood all over the script
effectively killing Ryan Reynolds and
then Deadpool says you're welcome Canada
which is freaking awesome I love this
scene probably more than anything again
Ryan Reynolds making fun of himself we
all know that he really did not like
Green Lantern they even made fun of it
in a skit that came out with David
Beckham just a few days before the movie
came out so that's it for the mid credit
scenes in Deadpool 2 if you're gonna
watch the movie let me know in the
comments below what you love the most
about it and if you haven't watched it
yet I hope I didn't spoil everything for
you be sure to subscribe to my channel I
will be doing more video
about Deadpool - and of course Marvel
and superhero videos details for the
giveaway are again in the description
below thank you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]